sosont menacés par la sécheress.
PéPénurie d'eau, manque de
prprécipitations et des récoltls
cocompromises, les effets néfass
sosont multiples. Des sécheresss
ququi pourraient même menacer
lala paix dans certains pays.
PoPour mieux comprendre l'impact
dede la raréfaction de l'eau et
dedes sécheresses, on reçoit
dedeux invités ce matin.
HoHossein Bonakdari, vous êtes
prprofesseur agrégé au départemt
dede génie civil de l'Université
d'd'Ottawa et Caroline
BrBrouillette, Directrice des
popolitiques nationales Réseau
acaction climat Canada.
B Bonjour à vous deux et merci
d'd'être présents ce matin.
- - Bonjour.
- - La crise est tellement
imimportante et globale. Les
EÉtats-Unis, la France, la Chin,
L'L'inde, le Chili, la Corne de
l'l'Afrique.. .Je commence par
vovous Caroline. Il est presque
inindéniable que les changements
clclimatiques sont au banc des
acaccusés. Maintenant qu'on a dt
çaça, quel est le rôle des
gogouvernements pour gérer ces
crcrises?
- - Écoutez, ce matin en
prpréparation de l'entrevue je
susuis allé relire le rapport du
GIGIEC sur les impacts pour
reregarder ce que la science nos
didit là-dessus et en fait, on
quque la science nous dit là-
dedessus et en fait, on sait qul
y y a 1,5 °C de réchauffement
clclimatique, on sait aujourd'hi
onon est à 1,2 déjà. Le risque e
sésécheresse dans le monde vient
dede doubler ces événements la
dedevienne non seulement plus
frfréquents mais également plus
inintense.
DoDonc la première chose à faire
enen paix pour réduire la tâche
d'd'adaptation, c'est d'atténuer
nonos émissions de gaz à effet e
seserre afin de limiter le
réréchauffement climatique souse
seseuil critique de 1,5 °C parce
quque au-delà de ça, on s'expose
auaux effets les plus intenses,
plplus sévères changements
clclimatiques comme les
sésécheresses, mais
mamalheureusement, ça ne se
rerestreint pas à ce type
d'd'événement climatique extrêm.
- - Alors ce sont quoi les
acaction concrète total des
gogouvernements parce que la la
baballe est un peu dans leur ca,
lala population a beau recycler,
changer son mode de transport,
onon fait de petites choses, mas
çaça ne prend pas un grand coupe
babarre de la part des
gogouvernements et surtout des
grgrandes puissances?
- - Tout à fait, je voyais votre
cocollègue juste maintenant parr
dudu plan de réduction
d'd'inflation, les États-Uninis,
c'c'est quand même un plan
hihistorique. C'est la première
fofois en 30 ans que les États-
UnUnis, principal émetteur mondl
hihistoriquement réussi à adoptr
unune législation sur les
chchangements climatiques. Donc
c'c'est significatif, mais ce
n'n'est pas suffisant parce que
nonotamment le plan continu de
prpromouvoir l'expansion de la
prproduction des énergies
fofossiles.
EtEt en fait, c'est un peu la me
chchose que l'on voit ici au
CaCanada, même si le Canada en
cocomparaison dépense moins à
trtravers le budget 2022, on a n
cacadre réglementaire qui est en
dédéveloppement. Ça va être
imimportant pour le gouvernement
dede bouger rapidement et de ne
papas laisser les industries
didiluer la qualité de ces
réréglementations la.
EtEt de l'autre côté, bien ça ns
enenvoie un signal que l'on doit
dodonner un coup de barre au
niniveau de l'investissement. Dc
onon doit augmenter la proportin
dudu financement public pour
rérépondre à la crise climatique
auau Canada. Et finalement, on
dodoit cesser de toujours
cocontinuer l'expansion de la
prproduction d'énergie fossile.n
sasait que le chancelier allemad
ScSchultz sera au Canada dans ls
prprochaines semaines. On entend
pepeut-être une entente sur la
liliquéfaction de gaz naturel sr
lala côte Est. Ce genre de projt
lala, alors que l'on voit les
imimpacts des changements
clclimatiques, ces verres partot
dadans le monde, je pense qu'il
fafaut nommer les choses, ça n'a
papas de bon sens de continuer à
veverser littéralement de l'huie
susur le feu.
- - Oui, c'est un peu
cocontradictoire. Vous êtes un
spspécialiste des sols. On sait
quque la croissance démographiq,
elelle existe. On aura de plus n
plplus d'humains sur la planète.
AlAlors commentaires avec plus e
popopulation, on doit produire
dadavantage de nourriture, que e
sosoit de la production bovine u
dede l'agriculture, comment faie
popour irriguer les terres
agagricoles et produire plus de
nonourriture toujours alors que
leles salons de la difficulté à
fofonctionner de maintenant.
- - Oui, tout à fait. Comme on
pepeut voir dans ces années-là,
nonous avons un déficit d'eau et
lele problème avec la production
agagricole et de la nourriture.
PoPour répondre à cette questio-
llà, vous savez, on a besoin d'n
nonombre très important pour...l
fafaut changer un peu la
tetechnologie. Il faut aller por
unune utilisation optimale de
l'l'eau pour la production
agagricole. Ce qui pose problème
popour le futur, pour ce que l'n
pepeut être sûr qu'il va arrive,
c'c'est un manque d'eau, surtout
quque l'on peut voir pour cette
anannée, on est expérimenté un
dédéficit d'autres importants en
EuEurope. Par exemple, environ 5
% % inférieurs de la normale au
momois de juillet en France. Ça,
çaça veut dire pour nous au
CaCanada, moment où on a besoin
d'd'eau pour produire, on n'a ps
asassez d'eau pourur faire de
l'l'agriculture, Gérard c'est pr
çaça qu'on a besoin de changer n
pepetit peu comme on a discuté
popour adapter, pour s'ajuster x
chchangements climatiques et
susurtout une adaptation à une
ututilisation optimale de l'eau.
- - Changements, adaptation, pas
bebeaucoup de nouvelles
tetechnologies pour nous aider y
ararriver mais on lit cette
sesemaine que dans des robes
tetechnologiques, que l'on parle
dede la Silicon Valley, de
BaBangalore, Taiwan, là aussi iy
a a des sécheresses importants.t
çaça prend de l'eau très pure
popourtant la production de ces
pupuces électroniques, de ces
mamatériaux. On est un peu dansn
cecercle vicieux, on a besoin de
ceces technologies pour avancer
mamais on n'y arrive pas
fifinalement.
- - Oui exactement, c'est ça le
prproblème.
- - Alors qu'est-ce que l'on fa,
ququelle est la solution?
- - Si je peux me permettre, je
pepense que la solution
mamalheureusement, elle n'est ps
tetechnologique mais elle est
plplutôt systémique. En fait, on
sasait que le tiers de la
prproduction mondiale de
nonourriture destinée à la
coconsommation humaine et
gagaspillée. L'enjeu, malgré la
crcroissance de la population et
mamalgré ce type d'événements qi
vovont devenir de plus en plus
exextrêmes, ce n'est pas de
rérépondre par une nouvelle
tetechnologie mais plutôt de
rerepenser nos systèmes et de
s's'assurer que le premier
obobjectif se soit en fait de
rérépondre aux besoins de tous.
IlIl y a la question du gaspille
alalimentaire qui est important
mamais aussi notre type
d'd'agriculture est extrêmement
exextractives. L'agriculture
inindustrielle impose sur le sol
vrvraiment un coût élevé, ce qui
fafait en sorte que le sol se
dedessèche plus rapidement. Il a
plplusieurs études qui démontret
quque l'agriculture ou on prend
sosoin du sol permet non seulemt
d'd'accumuler plus d'eau, mais e
séséquestrer également du carbo.
DoDonc il va falloir repenser
nonotre façon de faire les choss
sasans nécessairement recourir à
dede nouvelles technologies qui,
enen a tendance à penser, vont
vevenir nous sauver.
- - Miraculeusement
- - Et évaluer des options plus
crcréatives.
- - Justement le GIEC nous parlr
dudu fait que l'on doit revoir à
lala baisse, avoir une forme de
sosobriété dans notre mode de
coconsommation. C'est peut-êtree
quque vous dîtes. Est-ce qu'il y
auaura une guerre de l'or bleu
ququelque part sur la planète? n
vovoit déjà qu'il y a des tensis
dadans certains coins. Vous penz
quque ce sera un enjeu bientôt?
- - Vous voyait, moi je dois
ajajouter quelques petites phras
papar rapport aux technologies.e
vovoulais dire la nouvelle
tetechnologie pour l'irrigation,
lala nouvelle technologie pour
l'l'agriculture. Ça veut dire ue
ututilisation optimale de l'eau.
PaParce que la consommation plus
imimportante pour l'eau dans le
momonde, c'est la partie agricoe
ququi veut produire par exemplea
nonourriture, etc. o on parle de
tetechnologie, c'est plutôt la
papartie de production. Pour
l'l'utilisation optimale de l'e.
VoVoilà.
PaPar rapport au changement
clclimatique, c'est vrai, c'esta
réréalité. Comme on le sait très
bibien, on a besoin de plans à
lolong terme, surtout les faitse
sésécheresse, ça peut rester por
lolongtemps. Par exemple, moi je
pepeux vous assurer que le modèe
dede changement climatique monte
quque l'on va expérimenter la
sésécheresse très importante en
EuEurope parce que le modèle
momontre un changement de
clclimatique qui va bouger vers
l'l'Europe pour produire
leles saisons très sèches pour
l'l'avenir. De leur côté vous
vovoyait ce qui se passe, une
pepetite question pour le monde
ququi se pose. L'eau, elle va ù?
OnOn peut dire que nous avons un
pepetit changement. Par exemple
mamaintenant on voit le problème
dedes inondations en même temps
quque nous avons des inondations
enen Asie, en même temps que nos
avavons des problèmes de
sésécheresse en Europe. C'est
l'l'effet de ces changements qui
vovont arriver dans le futur qui
pepeuvent jouer sur l'ensemble e
lala planète.
- - Caroline, j'envie de vous
dedemander, votre organisation t
sosouvent dans les COP.
DaDans les COP on réclame beaucp
unune hausse du financement pour
leles pays développés, pour les
papays en développement de la pt
dedes pays développés. On octroe
cecertaines sommes mais on sait
quque les montants sont trop, tp
babas. Est-c-ce que c'est le tes
dede la part des pays développés
d'd'investir les sommes sont
vrvraiment nécessaires pour aidr
lele reste de la planète pour
s's'adapter à ces sécheresses
exextrêmes?
- - Tout à fait. En fait, non
seseulement l'argent que l'on a
prpromis aux pays du Sud, c'est
unune promesse qui est au sein e
l'l'accord de Paris. Les pays
s's'engagent à compter à réduire
leleurs émissions mais étant doé
leles iniquités dans la
reresponsabilité pour la crise
clclimatique, pays qui en sont e
plplus responsable sont ceux qui
reressemblent les moins pires
ététaient. Donc on s'est engagéà
memettre de l'argent sur la tabe
popour les pays du Sud : on s'et
dodonné une cible de 100 millias
ququi étaient un peu aléatoires.
OnOn a toujours pas atteinte. Et
cecet argent la est alloué en ps
grgrande proportion à
l'l'atténuation des changements
clclimatiques à l'adaptation.
DoDonc savait importante de venr
llà-bas augmenter le montant por
ququ'elle soit suffisant réponde
réréellement besoin. Donc ça va
alaller au-delà des 100 milliars
prpromis par les pays du Nord,
mamais également de rééquilibrer
lala proportion et cette année à
lala COP 27,1 enjeu qui va être
cecentral, c'est celui des perts
etet dommages. C'est-à-dire qu'-
dedelà de l'atténuation de
l'l'adaptation, il y a des impas
dedes changements climatiques qi
sosont simplement des pertes. Je
pepense simplement la destructin
tototale de la communauté de
l'l'automne en Colombie-
BrBritannique. On appelle ça une
peperte dommages et les pays du
SuSud envient davantage.
DoDonc on doit mettre sur pied n
mémécanisme qui va venir financr
seses pertes et dommages. C'est
unune question d'équité et de
jujustice climatique.
- - Alors vous êtes professeurs
agagrégés au département de géni